but I want to come to life but I can't -
how are you guys doing I hope you're
gonna help you doing all right I hope
you're Ramadan went really well I hope
your your I bet that was all good and
and I hope there was a lot of hair that
came from that now the reason why we're
doing this video is because there's
something that happened quite recently
in the Arab world and Soundwave in
particular actually funny enough and
which didn't get as much press here in
the english-speaking world so what
happened recently about a thousand two
hundred Islamic personalities Muftis big
scholars etc came from all different
parts of the Islamic world and when they
came they came to this conference right
and this conference was to uphold
certain values that have been frankly
lost in translation sometimes that would
be accused of as Muslims but they uphold
the values of for example a Thai or
which is a coexistence you know a mutual
coexistence living together tolerating
differences those kinds of values which
have been lost in translation and also
the fact that Islam is a is a race
inclusive religion that Islam is a
tolerant religion to other religions and
and so on and so forth now that's
important now why is it important
because obviously from a Western
perspective people will have issue with
those these are some of the key points
or why your skull is not speaking about
this well actually they are they have
and all those things people from all
different kinds of the Islamic world are
doing that but there's something
interesting about this now in some
Salafi corners frankly says sarahfey you
know practicing people there is this
idea that you know they say that if you
sit with the innovator if you sit with
the innovator then you become really an
innovator if you sit with the innovator
you are an interview if you sit with
something for a different grouping or
let's say for example classification or
if you say what the she I and you there
is no for example and you're not doing
dour to them or something like that or
for whatever reason then you become like
them so you can't you can't see with
them for common good and they would
consider this as anyone in principle a
principle of the Muslim Brotherhood days
it would say even though the for answers
with town or at our inviolability what
Tahoe and come together in mutual good
and and and impiety
so the thing is what's really
interesting is that in this meeting you
have people who are Shia you have people
who are Sufi but you also had to share
the mufti I'll share the main Mufti of
Saudi Arabia himself now I'm gonna get
straight to the point ladies and
gentlemen yeah this was something which
is worth a fight it was a big thing in
the Arab speak in the a in the Muslim
world you have people that came
literally and they would write in there
and they were it was written down that
this was for the Muslim out the great
the great a Muslim which means the
greater good the common interest of the
Muslim people it was for the common
interest of the Muslim people and people
from all sides Salafi Sophia and Shia
and they were coming together for those
reasons not to say ok we're going to all
believe in the same thing now he's gonna
be uniformity and belief they came
together for that muscle another
question is do you consider that a good
thing or a bad thing if you subscribe to
a certain kind of understanding of
Salafi or other strands of Islam larger
Salafism but other strands of Islamic
understanding then you would have
thought that this is a very negative
thing because if you are an innovator if
you're sing with you become one you
become an innovator but look look what
the King said the King said we're so
Luna and it makes us happy where you're
Sora and Nara all I'm a little humble
Islamiyah
ila had a town oh my god what did he say
can you repeat that in English he said
that it makes us happy to see it makes
us happy to see the ala man the scholars
of the Islamic world coming together in
this time one on on this process a town
as the Quran a town below her tower
means coming together in mutual good and
Tara's videos talk amazing good you good
and piety so that the king is saying is
good now
we're not here to defend Saudi women
politics that's a different discussion
obviously I'm just saying here for those
Salafis who do take Saudi Arabians
scholarship very very important and I'm
not saying we shouldn't take Saudi
Arabians well as you're very important
what do we say about this what do we say
about the king saying this is he
adopting a muslim brother is the
according to you is the muslim inducting
a Muslim Brotherhood methodology how
we say el chef himself who was sitting
the Mufti of Saudi Arabia is he to be
classed an innovator now actually since
he's doing this town I literally would
tuck well with people who are Shia and
Sophie and so on and if not really why
not
you've already taken out already a lot
of the people you've already taken out a
lot of the people of the Muslim world do
I do I thought all that man because of
this you've taken them out you've said
they're no longer Sydney yeah you've
said they no longer Sunni I said you've
said that you said that these people are
no longer certainly because they start
with the innovator why don't you apply
the same logic on the share the AL share
that the mufti I'll share the mufti of
Saudi Arabia come on
be consistent come on be consistent why
don't you come out and say that the king
is an iguana in your opinion do you
think that the king is a Muslim
Brotherhood I would think from the
politics that I'm observing that
actually he's quite a versatile Muslim
Brotherhood so I think that you're gonna
you're forced now to make a decision
either you consider you do exam you you
say that those individuals our
innovators those selfies that were
present in that meeting B Murphy him
yeah
with what is in them of the king and the
and the share and add the Mufti of Saudi
but oh you say you know what they have
other SMS Allah Vania is something which
is speculative rather than something
which is that I and so on and and this
is the thing there's gentlemen and
obviously my free table here my was my
discourse is targeted specifically to
Salafi is intolerant Salafis I'm just
gonna be straight for and I go I'll cosa
intolerant so interent to what
intolerant to intolerant to other
opinions and install it all the groups
now obviously there's tolerance everyone
is intolerance everywhere as well so
it's not just within
Salafism that we find this intolerance
we find inside winter tolerance within
every subgroup frankly right but my
hip-hop in this video is about that and
on that note I want to bring to your
attention I would say one of the most
despicable intolerant individuals of
honestly ever come across in this in
this in this country and
someone who has been who has been
speaking about our lemma and diet and
all of these individuals for a long time
this is an impostor I'm seeing it very
clearly this individuals in the pasta
this individual is a Charlotte and this
individual is a fake is a phony I'm
gonna prove it to you lazy Joe today I'm
gonna prove to you to this individual
he's fake yeah that any knowledge
acquired from that individual is going
to be a superficial fake knowledge which
is not even transmitted correctly
because the individual himself is fake
now who is this individuals name is
absolu head now you can see the camera
you can see the video you could sorry
the the picture on the screen right now
yes you see that individual there he
lives in Birmingham
he's a he claims to be a student of
knowledge in fact let's hear exactly
what kind of let's hear exactly what
kind of studies training he's done so
let's just a bit of what he said as for
where I studied then we'll a hunt and
all praise due to Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala I have been upon Salafi or what
we understood to be Salafi yeah since
the late 1980s since the late 1980s I
was introduced to salafiyyah
in around about 1988 my first in those
days of course this was you know
pre-computer pre-owned spree all of that
type of era so in that era our contact
with the Messiah canal ill ill was you
know scattered to say the least we have
some brothers who studied at the Islamic
University of Medina and they had some
contact with some of the great scholars
near like cher Abdul Aziz bin baz Shakur
Bruce a mean who of course alive at that
time and likewise the likes of Giovanni
and we would receive a lot of that
information by way of those brothers who
were studying then by about the mid 90s
or even before that then we are direct
ourselves myself I had some direct
contact with some of the Mushaf and some
of the students of knowledge who were
who had studied themselves and are
considered to be from a lil from them
were the likes of Sheikh Muhammad of
Allah and Mohammed Al and Jerry
to whom I studied and completed a
solution of imam muhammad of new husband
and the likes of from the other Messiah
of Kuwait under whom I studied the Ikeda
Abu Bakr al is Mihaly at all of course
the eighty father work at least my early
likewise in that same era meaning in the
early 90s or mid-90s I had studied below
Alma ram with those same Messiah and at
the same time we have started now
visiting the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia now
we can't watch the whole video a long
video but let me just summarize it for
you in a nutshell this individual his
training according to his own
testimonial right according to his own
testimony testimony is number one he
studied also lucilla so however you know
three or four major you know the the
book of Mohammed or Sunnah and the book
of two people called Rossi Rossi and
they're basically the same
and also he he said he studied blue mana
now the blue tomorrow is the only
significant book now this is not
significant training but this is not
even any training actually to be honest
with you this is basic training in fact
this is so basic that this individual
cannot be seen to be an authority by
anybody
despite this this individual who is has
such basic training he is coming out and
making temte of individuals he's taking
it upon himself to do the work of us a
scholar a much to hit someone who has
the ability to make rulings and do touch
big do ten deal take down and to
implement rulings on individual the
point is this individuals been doing it
with everyone let's see this so we've
talked about the level of qualification
according to himself he's not had any
formal qualifications he has no formal
qualifications that we know that we know
unless he comes out and says otherwise
but let's see his command of the Arabic
language in particular how he recites
the Quran o Shia we're jeon yul only one
where jalalahu
see higher uncle Hiram kathira
as Allah Jalla WA ala has taken
well occurred Menelik admin Allahu Allen
what meaning is a is bad after fee him
Rosalyn Menon him he has to do a
lay him IIT he were used up key him were
you and live over Maliki table while
hikmah were in car Newman ugly Mincha
below la fille de la Lima Bean Katya
come min allahi noon what is Abu moving
yeah DD he'll be Allahu min minute Sabah
read while ridwana who super loose
salawa you creature whom min of the
lumati Eleanor be evening
wellyeah DD he militarily most of him
has to be left as a lots of Amazonas it
a few on lava at Euro soon what would in
a bream income a lot of Albert Allah
mentioned yeah you had Navi Ghoulia's
Logica Woburn Attica 1 isa al-ma me Nina
you the Nina Ali in minja Lobby in women
UT allah rasool atiyullah yahwah's mal
arena and i'm oh la la when Allah Jalla
WA ala hostages semaj allah allah Sharia
terminal a mean rhasta b ha voila kotoba
wa ala inna llaha la moon in the
homeless - who knew in the home laguna
and uncommon allahi shia when the wine
Nadal I mean about whom all Yahoo bad
wallah Aliya Mustafina
and I know when I was growing up in
England they I I never went to a mosque
where the amount could even speak
English
the most I felt something was his back
hand when I didn't recite their first
properly that's the most we thought from
them
so the problem isn't that he can't
recite the Quran okay because they told
us you know Oh My yes mm relationship
fellow are on whoever struggles in the
recitation of Quran and it's difficult
for him and he gets to rule he gets to
rewards basically the problem is that
you have someone on that level of on
that net that that very lay level
frankly that lay level of knowledge
issuing fatwas and not only issuing
fatwas but high-level factors that have
far-reaching effects on people's lives
like tap dr for example which he's done
on me which is done on i was a fear the
CEO here and he's done on actually the
questions who has he not done it on and
he's done on everyone that I know so
this is this individual goes back to our
principle now if this is the reason why
I did it is because we say that you
should rely upon those things which we
agree on or for the Muslim Muslims not
saying that we change our beliefs then
why don't you make the tibia on the king
why they make this appeal and I'll share
make excuses from all day long because
people will think who will say that is
for political a strategic reason that
you're not doing it you're scared basic
Cameron I wouldn't blame you for being
scared just like frankly you've been
scared to come out and speak to people
that you do tip the of face to face
which you haven't done so you have been
you know rapping you've been putting
your head in the sand if you like yeah
you've been you've been scared of those
things but I say now the jig is up it's
over
we know now you level based on your own
testimonials based on your own
performance and we we know that your
you're basically in your lay person
people in Birmingham when they're
walking on the streets and they see they
should not think this is a shirt in
front of me you know because he's been
doing Dowell for god knows how many
years they should think okay this is a
person he's probably on the same level
of knowledge as I am because he their
ability of reading the Quran Arabic
language the things that almond Ella
alumina Ella the the basic not the I
need the knowledge of Allah which is
like the instrumental knowledge that you
need to have an Islam he does not have
so he's a white belt really he's a white
belt he's
your white belt and unfortunately he's
come out of his Lane by issuing these
four tower and these and making these
verdicts and this shows you the problem
with this understanding of Islam
generally speaking and what we need to
do is we need to save God our youth from
that frankly because it's a very
problematic mentality where you think
that it's not okay to be on good terms
and speak and and unite on that which is
good with Muslims but at the same time
you think it's all right to receive
prevent money and and this on the record
bro I'm sorry if you something record
why don't we talk to people that you and
your other acquaintances about Hakim or
Paul Davis the ex back bank robber that
forget her you know allo allo Allah you
know if he did that in Islam oh no I
don't know I know he robbed the bank and
well whether that report is true or not
is from some non-muslim sources but the
one who bought robbed the bank in his
past
possibly according to these sources and
you who are receiving prevent money
according to not just the news the news
media and I'm gonna put the I'm gonna
put the the the link in the description
all the links in the description all of
these things they can do you can do your
own research someone like that prevent
prevent money to do up and in reading
where you promise the people in the
messages that you were gonna do
activities for the youth ah what did you
do with the money what did you do with
the money
the second issue which was possibly a
first in terms of chronological order of
discussion was the issue of the
misappropriation of wealth our brothers
had made a wooden
occasion for some funding some council
funding and and the issuer that was the
that was what was being mentioned
and so we hear it the issue it turned
out that one of our brothers had put in
an application for some funding under
the name of an organization that was
working in collaboration with the name
or with in with the name that was given
to the Marcus leagues a smooth some
mistakes can be overlooked and some
mistakes cannot the error of the red
insurer or I became is not a small
mistake these people stole wealth using
the Deen of Allah to attain it in a
Haram way and you call it
a brother a new river oppressed to the
point where he said that this time of
his life where he was boycotted was very
difficult for him and you call it
nitpicking senilis you know who know
them for and I've not known except the
signal from them and I hopefully have
not know anything except the sinner from
us our relationship goes back a few
years but decades was a liquid Medina
and he's also known to the likes of
share hold a how can these markers the
outcome we said how can multiple cell at
the end of these dysfunctions and how
can they not be with us and we are upon
the same path and we are with the same
scholars so yes they are rumor monger a
skin ready rueful few years ago have
been rumor mongering and carrying tales
and closing beef it up and closing
enmity between the hearts of the
believers and that's been going on for
maybe in a few years maybe three years
or more and this is something that
actually was brought to me right at the
very beginning and from the start I said
that he sees love on a banner should be
to see
by our ranks that is not an issue that
necessitates division I wonder if
there's any spying activities involved
in the remit there because that would be
problematic again you know anyway if you
wanna see prevent money 2d radicalize do
you radicalize the youth the Muslim
youth do you Erica lies them and bring
them into a different kind of radicalism
which is the radicalism of believing
that well whoever is frankly that you
believe in terms of type D is all
radical no opinion I was speaking to one
individual communicating through that
individual to this into this underwire
head yeah and at one point I said to him
look knowledge is not contingent on man
henge so you can believe in all of the
right Islamic Sunni things and you can
still have low knowledge just like you
can have you can be a non Muslim and you
can be an alum in Islam it's very very
possible any Shaitaan was probably the
most knowledgeable of Allah than all of
us you know if you think it's
knowledgeable of Allah but it doesn't
mean because he's knowledgeable that he
has the right man hedge and that is the
right hire happy if I believe the truth
he doesn't believe in the truth so at
one point I'll tell you what made him
really angry this is what I made him
really angry I said to him cuz I know
he's got this beef with the SR kadhi
yeah I know he's got this beef with know
it has got beef cool justify they
wouldn't even acknowledge him let's be
honest yeah they're completely two
different levels
that's what party all of those
individuals you consider deviants you
know anyone at bilal philips any those
guys that you measure that you mentioned
in your publications who else well some
of their happy who's who has a message
that all of those guys you have to
attend their classes brother you have to
attend their classes because you don't
even know the place you should attend
their arabic basic class those guys that
I've just mentioned by name you should
attend their arabic basic classes and if
they happy to have you because brother
well who are you so you can't read the
quran and you're talking about people on
the level of that and then you're
talking about
Oh Sophia of the Salam Institute the CEO
of Salah are you talking about these
individuals bro come on the guys
memorize not only the Quran boys
memorize a Bihari and Muslim and his
memory as many books and he's a he's a
graduate from Medina University and he's
got the he's got the thing to--they he's
got he's got the Shahada well have you
got brother and that will be that but
I'm not going to leave you hanging
I'm go ahead I am gonna give you an
opportunity to because what we're doing
is we're doing a program called Salaam
plus and we're gonna travel I have some
things for basically like fundamentals
Islam we're gonna have like something's
like for example basic Arabic basic
Quran we want to put that on there I
fact I've gone my channel the Arabic
alphabet now I know that might sound
like you know the meaning I'm not trying
to mean you I'm just saying the maharaja
her off like you know just reuse god be
a beautiful pug maharaja lithography
Savatage or rather let the taro home and
about and you know 17 articulation
points and there's many different
institutes you can learn these things
from even by anna institute bayonetta 2
is doing a great job with arabic
language i know you don't like it
northern ali car I know they do but the
truth is they're doing a great job with
that I'm not sure and matter for doing I
know you would endorse them either but
in terms of Arabic and things like that
I'm sure you can go and learn from them
because whoever you've been learning
from frankly that's not he's not offered
your good service so that's what happens
when you separate yourself from
mainstream Dawa well you said when you
separate yourself from the the the the
the proper you know the the the most
effectual knowledge productions in the
Muslim world yeah and the
english-speaking Muslim on you when you
separate yourself from that you end up
being on an ineffectual individual
fiftieth I don't know how to Arbor in
terms of these things you need to have
them unlocked now bro because frankly
you're gonna be like a big share for
those guys in Birmingham that see you as
like some Imam or something